cette tour après 250 ans est érigé en
plein coeur de l'institut universitaire
en santé mentale de montréal
ce que l'on a longtemps appelé l'hôpital
louis h lafontaine
c'est jean de dieu l'audient responsable
des services techniques est l'un des
rares à y avoir accès cette tour est au
coeur de pierre et les gens on l'a
longtemps rappelé tour des monstres je
pense qu'avec beaucoup d'imaginaire on
avait une sorte d'appréhension pense
imaginer des choses terribles qui
pouvait se passer sur le terrain
d'hôpital un mythe qui traduit comment
nos perceptions de la maladie mentale
ont grandement évolué et les pop louange
ou marron ou où trouver des baumes et
rend sur le terrain d'hopital on venait
et on avait nommé rente quand on
revenait à montrer nos amis avec nos
mares on parlait surtout de ce qu'on
avait vu deux terribles d'effrayant à la
tour des visages des ombres décrit step
au vrai du tout là on n'a jamais vu ça
mais en inventer pour se donner de
l'importance et savez dans l'imaginaire
collectif de ce qu'est la représentation
de la folie de la maladie mentale de
l'époque pendant des décennies l'hôpital
c'était l'endroit où l'on cachait les
gens qui dérangeait le mandat l'époque
je crois que c'était en 1896 c'était de
nos rêves a été relogé les personnes
idiote ou kiko scandale c'était vraiment
le contrat entre le gouvernement et les
soeurs de la providence à l'époque alors
là on est rendu au quatrième étage qui
étaient placés qui est interdit en fait
c'était il y avait beaucoup de gens par
exemple des gens qui dérangent et qu'il
y avait une personnalité bizarre qui
avait un problème d'alcool
des fois des maladies mentales graves
des gens qui étaient dépressifs ou
anxieux qui étaient placés ici ou même
des gens qui étaient peut-être
d'apparence bizarre comme par exemple
qui avait un peu une déformation
du car des fois les gens les amener ici
à l'hôpital
et quand on entrait ici on ne sortait
pas et est hospitalisé sur une longue
longue période et rester ici parce que
c'est une ville autosuffisante y avait
jusqu'à 1947 autour de six mille deux
cents patients donc il y avait le faire
mais ils produisent leur propre
nourriture cuisine mais ici il faisait
beaucoup de métiers manuels aussi donc
les gens souvent ne ressortait pas dit
s'il travaillait sur la terre les
religieuses à l'époque croyais que ça
pouvait être bon pour leur santé mentale
l'hôpital c'était la ville dans la ville
incite tellement grand qu'il y avait
même un train pour transporter les gens
et les marchandises
puis dans les années 70 c'est le début
de la désinstitutionnalisation linda
fortier est embauché dans des années 80
la jeune fille qui venait chercher des
marrons a consacré sa vie
professionnelle à l'hôpital j'ai vu
l'évolution de la vision de la
psychiatrie l'évolution des services
aller vers quelque chose de mieux encore
du travail à faire mais définitivement
ça s'est amélioré avec le temps
dans les années 80 puis 90 il fallait
aider les patients à retrouver leur
place dans la société
j'ai notre dame qui était ainsi depuis
40 ans comme je le disais c'est un jeune
femme à l'époque qui avait juste le goût
de vivre sa vie de poids suivre
l'autorité de son père qui a été enfermé
était ici 40 ans puis l équité après 40
heures et elle s'est installée comme
s'il avait toujours vécu dans la
communauté vérité heureuse
graduellement les patients ont réintégré
la société de 4500 lits dans les années
soixante dix on est passé à moins de
2000 dans les années 90 année après
année la désinstitutionnalisation s'est
poursuivie les méthodes de traitement la
médication font en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
plus personne ne reste ici hospitalisés
en permanence et s'il reste 287 lit
c'est pour des séjours de courte ou de
moyens durs et les dortoirs où dormaient
jusqu'à une centaine de patients sont
maintenant rénover plusieurs transformée
en centre de formation
la maladie mentale grave en fait soit
environ 2% de la population comme par
exemple la schizophrénie la psychose
tandis que tout ce qui est problématique
de santé mentale plus légers ou modérés
comme par exemple la dépression
l'anxiété des trous dans le généraliser
on est capable de soigner ces gens
lançaient laissé à domicile d
accompagner dans la communauté il
nécessite pas nécessaire mais neuf
stabilisation pour le directeur de
l'institut la clé demeure le
développement des soins des services à
offrir
parce que quand on suit la personne dans
la communauté on peut aussi l'évalué à
l'extérieur des murs de l'hôpital donc
on est capable d'avoir les interactions
interactions sociales avec les gens son
réseau social sont cependant la
communauté c'est là qu'on peut faire une
pleine évaluation des de la personne
dans la communauté
ça nous prend des professionnels mais en
même temps ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
qu'à deux pas de la station qu'il
gardait des gens disent alors on est au
sommet de la tour on voit que c'est
toute une structure de bois et d'acier
qui date des années 1880 c'est leur
fameux reza voir qu'on voit ici c'est la
réserve d'eau très peu de gens ont monté
ici en haut
parce qu'on vienne démystifier un petit
peu les pouvoirs de la tôt
la peur de la maladie mentale a fait
apparaître des monstres aux fenêtres de
la tour mais personne n'a jamais été
enfermé ici la tour n'a toujours été
qu'un simple réservoir d'eau
[Musique]